okay for people joining this meeting
this is one of our infinite series of
incremental language development
meetings for wolf and language
and uh we've got a bunch of topics here
today um
[Music]
that um uh
will be for versions after 12 2 because
we're
wrapping up 12 2 imminently here so
let's get started
write logging data
yes what's that we have joel
to discuss this today right
so i mean my basic point is
a lot of systems find it useful to have
a notion of a log file
we don't really have that i mean clearly
you could just write something
you could say presumably except nobody
ever does it
um okay what's the what would be the
most convenient way to do this would it
be to have some central log file like
syslog on an operating system
that is a thing at a known place in your
file system that is the log file that
you choose to write would that be a
sensible thing for us to have
comments just one common file for
absolutely anything
well isn't that how operating systems
usually do it
there's logs for for different services
and then you know different people have
different opinions for different
purposes
about you know combining them or
whatever
i think that with logging flexibility is
is the big thing
well fair enough but i mean there's sort
of a generic log file
um and then um
uh and then maybe um
i mean what does syslog how does that
work
i mean this is i'm looking at the syslog
documentation
um
okay receives and processors log
messages
this is uh on linux well i try
actually very confusing here apple
system log
server why is it called apple system
this is the linux machine i'm on here
i thought it was uh
okay so this is a centralized
server the syslog daemon that
receives that is very much like our data
drop except that it's a more lightweight
thing that's just going directly to
files
right i mean there's an argument
there's an argument okay so let's let's
take a different point of view
let's take the point of view what if
there was a version of data drop
that just did nothing sophisticated just
wrote data to a file
as opposed to trying to you know
maintain something which is some kind of
data
you know database thing that has uh uh
sort of
um you know programmatic access so to
speak what if
it was that's like put put a pen to a
cloud object
is what that sounds like pretty much yes
but in a standardized way so that it has
you know like an apache log so it might
be in an apache log format
where it's you know where we could
actually read it in using our apache log
importer
where it has the you know the standard
timestamp and all that kind of stuff
right so when i think of logging one of
the things i think of is the sort of
template
and different systems that i've used in
even apache there's not one format
there's
a template language basically you know
do you want
uh the url do you want the method you
know so you put little percent
whatever's
in your format statement um what what is
that what is that
domain specific language there
it's the apache log configuration
maybe i i'm not sure i know i've messed
with it
but you know other log systems that that
i've used
are similar you know you have opinions
about what what you want to log
and time stamp is obviously one of them
but
you know it could also be you know the
machine you're on the process id
thread id you know all these you know
different things
fine but i mean what i'm suggesting is a
framework for people to routinely do
that
and yeah and we really could use
something like
you know just a log a logging
functionality um so you're suggesting
combining it either with
a centralized version or even a
cloud-based
um destination potentially i mean maybe
that i haven't really thought this
through but i mean maybe that's the
default
option is oh i'm just kind of because
you know a lot of times okay what is the
point what what feature
okay one feature of log files is most of
the time you'll never look at them
okay i mean that which is a very
different thing from most of the data
that we're dealing with i mean most data
like with data drop i think the the
implicit assumption is
you put the data in there you expect
somebody to look at it
right whereas with a log file it's you
put it in there and even if it takes
some effort to pull out the thing you
want
the very the point is that it's it was
lightweight to put it in there and it's
in there somewhere
and um so i mean what you're effectively
suggesting is
you know one could have for example a
one could even have a named a family of
things to write in the logging data
which could be you know let's say you
had a named collection of things to
write like what is the process id
what's the machine what's the time and
so on all kinds of environments
right but i mean but that that would be
a named thing and what you'd say is
write logging data of quotes
you know standard log blump that's it
that's all you put in your program
and and what that would do is it would
write it out with some kind of tag
perhaps in the log file if it's an
apache type log file maybe we have a
code
at the beginning of the line or
somewhere else or something that says
this is a type you know ax b
line and so then we can imagine an
importer
that you know in the event that it has
to import it can turn that into a nice
clean association
knowing that it's of that format type
for instance
i mean i don't know what you know i mean
obviously things like splunk specialize
in going through log files
yeah there's i mean with with web logs
there's the whole
echo system about ingesting these you
know i mean that's that's how
that's really what hadoop is doing is
it's going back through web logs to
you know calculate traffic and things
about your website well right
now in our implementation for example
but but um
but i mean in but that's okay
the log file is an http server is that
standardized or is that
also a you know a jungle
i mean when you say apache logs you know
they were invented for the apache
http server right yes that's
okay so is that then standardized what
an http server writes out i mean or does
tomcat write different things and just
tomcat has a different i mean well
tomcat
there's tomcat itself which does logging
right at the beginning but then
every individual application you deploy
to a tomcat server
could theoretically do you know
absolutely
different things yeah i understand but
theoretically in our language you can
write anything you want into any file
you want
right the goal here is to make a dead
simple framework
where somebody can just put in in a
random place in their code right logging
data
bump there it is and um you know and
then we provide some tools to go look at
those logs later
and where routinely i mean i would do
that in
you know in you know i do long runs of
computations for example
and i try and log a bunch of stuff for
those but
every time i do it i have to custom
write a bunch of stuff that puts this in
files and i have to remember where the
files are and this and that and the
other
but if i just wanted to know oh i come
back in the morning and my machine is
is crashed on the floor you know what
happened
right if i had put a right logging data
thing
in some loop somewhere i would have
known you know i just go look at the log
file
but 99 times over 100 i'll never look at
the log file because i don't care
because it just worked fine um
and uh so that's what i'm suggesting so
i mean my question is
uh oh if we had that point of view
that there is a standardized location
for a log file
and that most of the time you just put
it in there and that we provide some
tools maybe in the function repository
for reading back from the log file that
say things like
just look at the last hour of logs you
know something went wrong just look at
the last hour of logs
or you know things that i've done
depressingly often
you know when it's fallen to me to debug
some messy thing in our company
it's like you ingest the you know you
you do some something where you're using
you know uh various kinds of string
manipulation functions to ingest pieces
of the log files and so on
and then you're generating you know nice
similarization
nice things from that the um
uh yeah steve
steve is the live stream is suggesting
that it will be an interesting thing to
be able to use things like machine
learning to pull out interesting
features of logs you know
i have to say it's like data scraping
you know i've done this a bunch of times
i've done this debugging craziness in
the cloud i even wrote a blog post about
doing that at one time
where where you know it's it's a crazy
adventure like we were trying to find
out maybe you weren't even involved in
that
joel well we had these mutex locks right
we were trying to find out
what created the lock what destroyed the
lock we were seeing the two ends of the
lock
you know deeply interspersed with all
kinds of other crud in the logs
and that was a non-trivial exercise in
you know
scrapery basically to pull out what was
what was relevant there
and i i have a feeling there probably
isn't a global solution
but um uh you know the thing we're
trying to do here
is to make it straightforward for people
to log what's happening in their welfare
language sessions
to make it so lightweight that you know
people routinely put the stuff in there
and possibly even that people want to
put in their initialization files
so that when they start a session or
where an api starts a session
but it puts something in the log i mean
like for example
when you call an api function it could
be the case that you would really want
that to just
throw something to the logs
i mean we are throwing something into
logs right now in the cloud
in our whole i don't know whether it's
kafka eyes yet but you know that whole
messaging system
is throwing information to the lot to
the logs about the use of the api
but a user might want to do that as well
and tasks do that from the beginning
every task has its own
master log file um
and it has it's it's not directly
writable by the user but
just the idea that of associating a log
file with each object or something
uh makes sense right well i mean so so
maybe what we want to do
is maybe we need to define what the
standard where you say write logging
data
just write logging data open close what
does that write out
okay and um uh
you know and maybe it's something quite
simple but um
i mean you know there's so many things
that could write out you know dollar
command line it could write out you know
what was the evaluation environment what
was this what was that it doesn't want
to write out too much stuff
yeah i i think it wants to write like
cpu and memory statistics
sure things like that yep but i mean i
think if we design that
then i mean as i say what i want to see
is for people doing serious
stuff you know just
you know in the event of disaster go
back and look at the log file
and get have some idea what happened
so how can we move forward on this and i
mean in terms of writing the log file
out
presumably we can use the operating
systems file system lock if it's just
going to
uh just a generic well actually this
isn't so obvious to me but
explain how this would work both on the
desktop and the cloud
so you would acquire basically you've
got multiple assume you have multiple
warfarm engines running
right and they're going to they're
trying to write into a file
is it or is it not the case that when
you do an f open
on on um uh in the operating system
does that what does that do if another
process is opening the same file
yeah i'm i'm hazy on what what it does
in different systems and also different
file systems will behave differently i
know that nfs
file systems you know you're potentially
going to
uh corrupt things if you open it to
append
uh there may be so we need a lot more
guarantees make this work
it would be good yeah or alternatively
we piggyback on the syslog d
mechanism of the operating system so but
your
your main point is that by default they
all go to the same file
it's not separated by process id or
something that's what i would think
yeah i mean it's like something went
wrong let me look at my
you know wolfram engine you know wolfram
log file
and you know it's the same thing that i
see
i don't know like like on my computer
right there's a there's a centralized
log file which i occasionally look at it
just contains all kinds of crud
about all kinds of random device drivers
that were timing out and all kinds of
things like that
right and usually i don't ever look at
that file but when something goes
horribly wrong i do
and i think it's useful to have it be
centralized because otherwise you're
like oh where can i find this particular
file
did i lose you no okay
i mean and then you know we can have
something where you say write logging
data and then
give um you know a file destination or a
persistence i think what we want to do
is a persistence location
of some kind so you can say write
logging data to the cloud
write logging data to my local machine
and then a default name for where you
write it
and if you don't want the default you
put it you know if it's a special
log for some particular um
you know i mean i might choose to write
the the great results of my computer
experiment into a log file because this
is a convenient mechanism
i mean i have a bad feeling that we may
find that this mechanism
is a more useful thing in some ways than
the data drop for some purposes i mean
data drop
produces an immediately computable
output that's immediately usable
this is producing a pretty dead output
that will have to be scraped in order to
be useful
right um
well it would be nice to have uh either
a dollar variable or yeah some some
options so that if you you know if you
call a function the function may decide
i'm going to log to a different place i
need to set these things right but then
restore it
at the end so i don't know if that's
what you're saying a dollar default
logging
location or something yeah right is the
is the default value for that in
right logging data but you can reset
that in some way
yeah no it makes sense but i mean okay
but but so the
the real challenge is you're writing to
a file
i mean look this might be a more general
function in the end
which just says write to a file safely
even though there may be multiple
processors trying to write to this file
how do you do that in general in in the
um
uh yeah you'd have to clean a lock file
yeah you'd have to get it well you'd
have to get a like something like a
mutex from the os
whatever whatever makes sense on the
different operating systems and i was
going to say that
that the kernel has you know a
generalized interface to
uh to a mutex and in critical sections
and different things like that
that this would want to take advantage
of
okay okay but i mean or is there a more
simple-minded way of just writing out a
lock file
i don't know i mean you know i know back
in the day lots of programs used to use
that kind of mechanism
although it would fail from time to time
you'd have to go and remove the lock
file manually which is
which is you know very painful
i i think the most systems there's
there's a
very fast lock that will you know that
will guarantee you that
it's probably the right thing to do okay
fine i haven't looked at these details
in a while in the kernel
but well look this is i think let's try
and iterate to get some design of what
we think it will be useful
and this is a question to ask um
perhaps tech support perhaps some other
people who would be
uh consumers of these log files you know
what what will we try to log
with i think a budget of 200 characters
per line
okay maybe i maybe i'm wrong about that
limit maybe it should be less than that
maybe more than that but that's the on
the order
that's the order of magnitude limit for
how much we should log
yeah i don't even know if you
need to put much of a limit
well i but but my whole point is i don't
want to see
in these log files that we're logging
the whole you know kitchen sink
and that okay because there are other
issues that are
you mean the default behavior yeah i
mean the default behavior oh sure sure
yeah
i don't know we don't have to limit it
for a user wants to write the long thing
out that's fine
yeah got it and the user wants to write
binary data out that's fine but but
that's not going to be the default
yeah the default is ascii comparatively
short um
i think bob here is mentioning
a q system i don't know what um i mean
yes to cue up the output
to queue up the things that have to go
into the log files yes i mean
you don't want to lose it just like
we're doing for the data drop now
the data drop is is i hope been fully
set up so that things cue and do not get
lost right
uh well that that development is is
queued up
okay queuing is cued okay
well fine um all right let's go on to
the next topic i think
we're done with this one if that's um um
sorry i think i have a question i was
thinking about this login idea
and i was thinking of these situations
in which users or you
send an email saying why was this
geographic so slow
and i was wondering is there any way of
actually having some login of some
functions
that then we can explore a posteriori to
see what happened
well i mean in that particular case it
was going to the server right
yes but from the front from the point of
view of the client so
i was thinking perhaps there is a way of
making the function
write something it might be memory
something that can be explored
after the fact after the function has
evaluated
the function may have been writing
something to somebody memory or a file
where we can look at well right i mean
that that's essentially in operating
systems and and god i'm so out of date
with these things
there used to be these what is it called
trace what the heck is it called it's
it's the
some way of running an operating system
so that you can on an operating system a
a
a cpu so that you're tracing every
operation what does that call
p trace i don't remember what it's
called anybody know joel do you know
well s trace can show you system calls
that's what you're thinking i think
that's the thing i'm thinking of yes
yes but that's and what is that again
it's just uh showing you system calls
that the program is making so even if
you don't have the source you can see oh
it did an f open on this
path or something but that's that's a
mode of running the executable
so that you are tracing system calls
yeah
is that right more or less
i mean i think that that um because i
think
what jose is asking
i mean i i don't think it's realistic to
be storing all this data
you know all the time i think the only
you know you could run it
again with this kind of trace mode
enabled that seems like the realistic
thing to do
right so i mean there is a way of
activating
say debugging information in say
geographics
but of course this can be done
i mean it may i don't know how to say
so it would be good to be able to
activate it a posteriori right
it wasn't shown but if something
happened it would be nice to see the
posteriori
well perhaps the next time it doesn't
right but so i would make them
a different suggestion which is you know
which relates to my messages that are
off by default thing but the
there's one bizarre possibility would be
in some things like geographics where
you have to call a server and so on
there could be something where if that
is called within
a you know uh uh
i don't know let's imagine it's called
the logging block
not probably the right name but but you
know something like this
if it's called within a logging block
then all those functions which have the
ability to
to generate log files will do so
so for example in in the case where
uh in the case of these things that have
to go to the to a server
to get data like you know entity lookups
like all these kinds of things
inside a logging block they would be
writing that
in the fact that they are doing that to
the log file
normally they wouldn't but if you said
logging block of that then they would do
that
let's say
let's see i mean in other words the main
issue is
right now look you know many systems
have the notion you know set debug
on whatever that means it's usually very
undefined
and it's usually very uh you know
capricious on the part of one program
and did something another didn't and so
on
but i mean the suggestion here would be
to try and somewhat
you know to to particularly
to log all network calls because those
are things that could get slow or could
have problems or could
you know whatever and then we could go
on and start logging other kinds of
things
and and the notion would be rather than
generating these things as
well okay so so the immediate thing
people are going to want if we give them
logging block
which logs to an external file is
they're going to say i want to see that
stuff in my notebook
interactively
and that then goes down a slippery slope
of essentially messages off by default
but this is a different mechanism
perhaps for doing that type of thing
right
i was thinking perhaps of having a
dollar variable that you can consult
after the evaluation to see whether
something it's a bit like the stack
trace of when there are messages
that's very useful too it is very useful
yes
to detect to detect what happened
you know isn't it the case this is so
pathetic that i don't even know this
that do we still store the time of every
output line
i think i'm losing my i'm losing my mind
because i remember
in smp which means 40 years ago that
you know there used to be a hash i for
the input over the output and hash t
for the time for each output line do we
have that
i've forgotten i'm horrified to say i
don't remember
whether that's something that we've ever
implemented i think the cells
store the time not the timing but the
time the absolute time of evaluation no
they do store that because you can see
that in the notebook history
but but um um we
gosh we never did that okay well that
was one of those features that
um uh that i guess i thought wasn't
important
and the fact that i don't remember i
mean okay but i mean that's the most
minimal thing what you're saying is
that are you suggesting something
see because that's you know what you'll
end up with is
you know uh you know out logs
or something of 17 is what were the
things that were because you definitely
don't want to do
um something where
you know where it's just a single dollar
variable it's overwritten the next time
you have an output line that's that's
just a formula for people to be super
frustrated
oh my gosh i got this amazing you know
this amazing error case
oh shoot i just you know uh
overwrote it i don't think that's a
desirable situation but the idea of a
you know out logging or something
of of 17 uh putting something in there
so that's an interesting idea that that
this could work with um
so the the idea would be that this
logging block thing
in addition to writing to an external
log file or
instead of or something could also write
to essentially an
internal log which is
a something that is associated with
these output lines
right to compare for example what with a
previous evaluation
yeah well it's an interesting idea to
have
what this is effectively is i mean
this says wait a minute don't we have a
mechanism i'm so embarrassed i don't
know this
yes message list i'm not as crazy as i
as i thought i was look that gives you
and the fact that nobody here even knows
this
that's the list of messages so if i go
here
and i say message list slash at range
minus range of of 50 or something
okay that's kind of cool did you even
know you could do that
i never i never tried that before so
that's telling me
for the last okay i'm now curious if i
do this
over i'm at line 926 so i'm going to go
to range
this is going to show me for my whole
range 926
and let me let's say let's delete cases
just to avoid
total craziness delete cases of null
list
okay so this shows me that's in this
session that is the complete list of
error messages that i encountered in
this session
it's kind of interesting interesting i
never looked at this before
so this
is um so so for example here i'm now i'm
now really curious i can say
counts of that and
oh i see i don't want to do that i want
to say counts of flattened
okay
okay general stop vertex list arg
t um
yeah jonas is pointing out you can
replay the input the fact is you can
replay the input that's why
it says 930 colon equals if you simply
type in of 930 you'll re-execute line
930
and if i type in of 930 it'll just
re-execute it
um so
okay so what this look this is in the
category
of something which i think is a general
thing we should be thinking about
which is again my messages off by
default
things that aren't definitively wrong
but a kind of iffy
um that we know happened and the
question is
you know the difficulty is how do we do
that consistently how do we
across 6000 functions how do we
consistently put in messages well the
answer is we're not going to be able to
do that
so what will have to happen is over time
we'll just gradually add messages and
it'll all be a bit of a mess
just as log files are a bit of a mess
but if the log file happens to contain
what you want
you're a happy person
but i think this is in the category of
you know we can start off by
i think this notion of a message rather
than a
what can i say a um no a a
a log message rather than an error
message is a useful way to think about
this
right and so what we're suggesting here
then is that for every output line just
like we accumulate message list
um we could say you know
logging list or something of whatever
and then this would be
a okay so then what would happen is
we could have something that's a logging
block which is like
a so reaped or like a timing type thing
where it brings back in or it could even
be called logging of exper or something
which would then bring back um not just
the result of expert but also just like
timing does
the um you know the log list so to speak
and that would be well there could be
things that are written to the log file
by default look i think this is in the
general category of
uh you know okay there's different
mechanisms here one is a standardized
log which is very much at a system level
another is much more application level
um
right kobe is commenting that if we had
logging information we would be able to
have more accurate error messages
yeah i don't know if that's true i mean
but just being able to give more context
for the message is always useful and i
agree that our
you know that mechanism that we added
only a few years ago
for dealing with um uh you know where we
can say
um uh you know
um we do something like this
uh that's not a good example is it what
do i want to do how do i want to get am
how do i get a good message here how do
i get something which is generating a
message
oh i don't know let's say
okay there we go now the fact that we
can go into that message and say show
stack trace
that's really useful
might be even more useful in this case
if it said that x equals 10
in the case where it's failing but even
this is already useful
okay let me show you an idea that i had
about trace yesterday
that actually max already implemented
something so trace
a famously a famously unused function
um okay let's see if i can
can demo already
um i use trace print quite a lot
yeah okay
sorry i said that i also use trace print
quite a lot
okay well this is what is this this was
an attempt
to make something i just thought of
yesterday and see whether it does what
what max said it would do this just code
that he just sent me let me just type
the example that he
gave here or roughly
i don't know what module scope is doing
but what this is doing
is this is showing the evaluation
history of
that expression
right so i mean i you know this may be
still too obscure
but the idea is this is showing it's
like causal graphs
in our physics project okay that's
needless to say that's where it came
from
it's like where did this result come
from
right so there's something here which is
saying
i don't understand what the heck's going
on here what on earth is going on
oh i see why is that 16 not contributing
down to the 18
i'm confused by that
i think there are arrows going the wrong
way here
i i don't understand this but a trace
view something that
can visualize the trace because the
problem with traces that is usually so
large
that is difficult to navigate well i
agree so the question is can we make a
graph
you know when we invented trace in 1990
we did not have the notion of graphs
well more than a graph is something like
something that has openers so that you
can decide which
path well yes right i mean that's that's
a different thing is a trace print
that prints into a notebook which has
openers right
that's something we should try to do i
mean i i don't even i haven't used trace
print in so long
um see what this does in that case but
the problem with trace print yeah
the problem is i've just been in my
obsession with combinators i've just
been studying this
the difference between reevaluation
recursion
and expression traversal recursion
see what i'm saying and those two things
are not distinguished and trace print
properly
in other words if i say if i do
something where i
say um
you know three five times six
seven five plus eight etc and i say
trace print that
there are two kinds of recursion that
are going on there actually i i no
let me go here six times
five six plus eight or
and even more well i could probably have
a better example here but but
the difficulty is that i'm not
distinguishing here between
walking through the list
and going into one of these actually the
worst cases
f goes to g goes to h goes to i whatever
a succession of things in evaluation so
for example if i were to say
x equals y equals seven or so where x
equals seven uh y equals
x plus eight etcetera now let me go
trace print
of list four plus five
four plus x four plus y
okay so part of that evaluation chain
is the x turning into seven
right so i think because you are losing
the nesting
of trace here it's difficult to follow
yes i think trace print is more useful
with a second argument in which you
specify
which actual expressions you are
interested in
and that's very useful even in huge
expressions
fair enough yeah that's how i'm using it
for example i
i've placed in the in the chat a link to
a mathematical stacks change post
with some ideas for trace views
okay
which has some implementation of this
stuff right
yeah there's some nice nice things here
yeah i mean something like this is
probably i mean look this
is again in expression browsing this is
a
trace view is a particular example i
think of expression browsing
exactly yeah this type of thing at the
end with openers
that you can select
you can sequentially select the part
you're interested
in that's that's pretty useful
yes i i agree i mean i think that um
you know
i mean that's the question of expression
browse
which we've also talked about at length
and we really should get to do at some
point
where but i mean that's also related to
the too big business and whether you
should be able to click on
you know when you get a too big output
should you be able to just click on
um you know something like this should
you be able to click on that
rather than doing this global show more
right right exactly
look i think we should add to i don't
know whether we have this on the global
project list the expression browsing
thing it's something we should
look at and we should probably have a
couple of design meetings and see if
whether we can finally nail this one
and as part of that we should talk about
trace print
um people in the live stream are talking
about
um the debugger and the life and times
of the debugger
um you know unfortunately it just didn't
work very well you know it just
hasn't been a big you know i don't know
what
can anybody why are there two copies of
this
oh because i have two different kernels
running here and it made two copies
okay quest two questions who uses the
debugger
and why has the debugger been as
comparatively unsuccessful as it has
i mean clearly one major reason is
because
a step-by-step debugger is good if
you're doing a procedural language i
mean
in fact i was just writing about this in
my in my story about combinators
you know the big idea of functional
programming is you don't have to be
picking out the program counter you know
in a procedural language where you go
from here to there to there to there to
there to that to there
then you are essentially walking through
you know program counter space
and you always know there is a current
state and so the notion of stepping in a
debugger makes perfect sense
when you have a functional programming
you are essentially uh
you know you're you're eliding and
collecting a lot of that control flow
and it's much less obvious how the how
the stepping
action of a debugger should work in the
case where for example you can have
sort of you know where you're doing an
operation that's listable and you're
going across a whole bunch of elements
and so on
what does the debugger do does the
debugger kind of
i mean is the debugger essentially
tracing the
operation of the evaluator or what is it
doing
i mean clearly the fact that traceprint
can do something
indicates the debugger can do something
as well but
the notion of step over and so on i
think is much less clear in a functional
situation than it is in
in procedural you know code
but do anybody want to comment on on the
sake of the debugger
who uses the debugger here i haven't
used it in years now
i i don't use it no but i use
i use trace and respring text for
example something i do very very
frequently
is that when there is a message and i
don't know where it's coming from
i compute the whole trace then i search
for the message
i go directly to the previous expression
and i know where it has been generated
why can't you do that from the stack
trace
because sometimes the stack trace
doesn't show uh
all the steps right if it gets too
internal
it will stop yeah okay fair enough but
there's another reason which is the
stack trace
is where you are nested
in um again it's this
issue between expression traversal
versus reevaluation
recursion right and sometimes you have
to know
the previous expressions not the actual
one that generated
things because you want to know what
happened before
well okay so the question sandra is
commenting that
that um he still can't figure he doesn't
know what's wrong with the debugger yes
i think we all have this experience
that the debugger was unusable but we
just don't quite know why
anybody else want to comment on that
here
jose why do you not use the debugger
i have tried a few times and i think i
just get confused because i i'm
i don't use the debugger much either in
c so i'm
i i just
don't have the the mindset of of using
the debugger
in general well with trace i have access
to the whole expression
at the same time and i like this well i
know but i mean this this notion of
being able to do computable things
look the whole idea of trace this was a
long-running story of mine
to try to represent the essentially you
know space-time history of a computation
okay that was the idea of trace that you
could pick up the whole computation
and compute things about the
you know the the temporal sequence of a
computation
unfortunately well it wasn't as usable
as i had hoped
now maybe using graphs and things we
could make it much more usable
or possibly using this i mean really the
combination is
is probably the most powerful thing the
combination of both graphs because
in your uh whatever you know advent
calendar windows
type idea where you're opening things up
and seeing what's inside
um the uh
you know that's still in the most
obvious way of implementing that that's
still going to be quite linear
and maybe the thing that we ultimately
want is what we're working towards with
graphs
which is the ability as you have in
things like system modeler given a graph
you can click on double click a node
which is at first a summary node and
then you can open it up and see what's
underneath that
so
ethan is commenting that um uh
the bugger in python is essential but i
you know well we just don't know
um
it uh yeah comments about debuggers here
okay okay so i know danny uses the the
debugging c
quite a lot but do you use it in in top
level danny
no i do not
i think i used it years ago um
when i worked on alpha and uh
uh the uh workbench
i use the workbench debugger but i don't
think i've ever used the built-in one
what is the the workbench debugger
various people are saying that that's a
nicer
thing but what what is it is this going
to crash my session
to show all for this trace of plot
um
okay ethan is saying nobody thinks in
terms of graphs
maybe you're right i mean you know one
of the mysteries of combinators is why
the idea of
unnamed variables has never caught on
and it is true that i you know you can
deal with that in a graph-based way and
it's really really hard to understand
boy my poor machine don't crash my
session i hope you're not going to crash
my session here because
this session had a bunch of useful
things in it as the fact that we're on
line 947 might suggest
um i use debuggers in both
for a lot of you know java and things
like that
and i do try to program in a functional
style
um even when i'm doing imperative stuff
and you run into the same thing in the
debugger if you have a heavily nested
expression
step into steps into more than you care
to most of the time
and the java debuggers will have
ways to say you know exclude this
you know native library i don't want to
step into the java implementation of
strings
and things like that so there's there's
a ux
to exclude things from being step step
in the bowl
and once you have that filter then you
you know
it's this is getting back to why i use
trace print with the second argument
i i can specify only show me things that
are calls to these functions that are
that are of interest so it seems like
that's going to be part of it
is just specifying what you're
interested in stopping at
yeah yeah this this output is
you know look what happened here is a
lot of things that would usually just be
pointers in memory
just got disgorged into you know into a
giant structure here
which is incredibly non-useful i agree
um the
i'm still not giving up on the idea of
using graphs in some way
to represent uh the flow of information
and i mean i literally have just
understood
like with combinators my my favorite
topic of the week
um causal graphs finally show me what
the heck is going on
which i just could not figure out at all
from looking at the actual expressions
and so on
and this isn't an adequate causal graph
so this is not doing the right thing
here
but it's still um and this is inadequate
this is
clearly not not useful here um
the uh
yeah i mean look i
i do think we should okay clearly this
comes up every so often
you know this what are we going to do
with the debugger what what should we
you know okay let me just comment
this wasn't what the direction of this
meeting you know the code assistance
project
is the best way you know
prevention is better than diagnosis and
and
and treatment so to speak the best way
to
you know the best way to avoid you know
once you're in a debugger
you're already you know sort of
behind so to speak the best thing is
write correct code in the first place
and that's why there's a big emphasis on
code assistance
and the question is can a lot of the
things what which land went up in the
debugger i mean
the the fact is look you know i write
tons of code
and occasionally you know
the number of times when i'm like
looking at it and scratching my head and
really confused
is not all that large well i had one on
a live stream actually a couple of days
ago which was which i still don't know
the answer to
which was a deeply uh which actually
would have been a good example it's a
very
very bizarre thing of something
capturing some variable
somehow in some you know piece of code
and actually it's a bad sign they didn't
even think of using trace and so on to
debug that
um probably didn't help that it had
module variables in it and as soon as
you have module variables
you again you know the idea because you
don't know what the name of the variable
is going to be you have another kind of
worms there
but look i think code assistance
prevention of
bugs is the best first step
then the next question is then things
like the stack trace
business is good to you know the sort of
situational awareness of what caused the
bug
and then the next question is is
you know is it useful to be able to
interactively step is it more useful to
be able to have a data structure that
you can then analyze
you know where is the real utility you
know the reason to have a a stepping
type thing is
oh you know for example one of the
principles of debugging is
do you expect that you're going to be
able to rerun the code and get the same
bug to occur
if you're trying to debug when you do
not have that kind of reproducibility
you've got a different problem on your
hands
and that's where all this logging stuff
is relevant and so on but assuming it's
reproducible
i mean back in the day you know one
always used to worry about
oh you know i'll put a break point in
this piece of c code or something
because i don't want to you you didn't
have the assumption i can just run it
again
and you know with some just different
instrumentation
um anyway i think i think this requires
a custom meeting which this is not um
so i think we should move on here to the
next item which unfortunately is not
completely unrelated
oh boy boy um it's really
smp redux time this is
a right controlled release hold
the the enthusiasm is palpable
so is this related to your discussion
yesterday of the different
ways of traversing for evaluation
somewhat yes i you know we're not ready
for this
that this is this is another this is a
discussion to be had once we understand
traversal orders
and other things i mean there's very
subtle issues
these are all together all these things
about the the causal graphs
of evaluation the traversal orders
the recursion you know uh sequence et
cetera et cetera et cetera they're all a
related set of things
they're all rather interesting and
rather deep kind of
issues yeah but probably these two
so yeah you sent an email about these
but yeah well that's the same thing
that's related to all these things
they're all
they're all connected yeah okay um so is
this
actually
that's a that's a piece of mixture of
history and obscurity
that um uh i think um
we should uh let's see this is okay
there's a function repository item for
expression viewer
um
oh yeah interesting
right yeah this is exactly the kind of
thing
that you know this expression browse
thing it's exactly the kind of thing
i was thinking about the thing is what's
needed is a bunch of heuristics that
don't line you up with this type of
stuff
because that's just annoying yeah and
it's like
what it's like it's like you know a
thing that um
um uh
you know what was i going to say yeah
it's like common sub expressions right
we we've
at different times and i don't know
whether the things in the function
repository for doing this it's like
you know you solve a cubic equation it's
a big mess
you say i would prefer to define some
intermediate variables
okay question is which intermediate
variables
you know because if you define it all
the way with intermediate variables and
you have kind of a dag
representation it's absolutely
incomprehensible as well
right so what lumps do you define
as your sort of intermediate variables
what lumps do you define
as the thing that is a you know
a browser element as opposed to just
uh giving it literally i mean like this
rule this is just wrong it shouldn't be
like that it should just be
one arrow two perhaps it's you know what
elides now
you know back the original short code
which hopefully has been
rewritten long you know i mean i wrote
that original
code for doing shortening of expressions
on output
um which uses a bunch of heuristics like
it always has two-thirds one-third you
know
if you give a long list it'll show you
the first two thirds then an illusion
than the last one-third type thing
um which i think is useful but there's a
there's a whole collection of heuristics
about
what level of granularity to to use here
and maybe there's a way to parameterize
it i'm not sure
um
okay let's go on here
okay position largest
okay i seem to need this function
ridiculously often
what i'm doing is i'm i'm trying to find
the position of max
in a i mean so
really um
i mean is it the case that what i'm
really asking for is positioned by
yeah you also might want to ask yourself
why max is hiding from you in the first
place but i guess that's another
discussion
what you said you wanted the position of
max
what can i say oh i said i i see
not quick enough there
i mean position buy would do it yeah
well the thing is
generalizes better so that we don't have
the situation like the uh
take largest family where we have
multiple maintenance lots of
documentation knitting and et cetera et
cetera
i don't think i find technologists very
useful i i agree with that i just think
that
we we have this proliferation of four
functions
where maybe we needed that i don't know
but in this case i don't think we do
yeah okay fine but i mean so so the
issue is
i'm trying to find the position
of let's just understand the definition
of this you know
what
what earth i i've i'm not you know i've
never used position index i know we have
that
what does it do um
yeah it's it's it's saying four it's
found that position one
five is found at positions two and six
so i have discussed the idea of position
largest several times in the past and we
always got stuck
in two things one is whether to return a
list of numbers or a return or a list of
lists
because we have to respect the name
position and the other one
was the fact that sometimes or
frequently we wanted both
what is the max and what it is and
that's why we came up with the idea of
combining both things
in technologies well what about
position index having a second argument
to do what to that's a filter
that basically says i only want the
position index of the max in this list
i mean this return would look very much
like the return which i don't like very
much of you know
uh constrain men or something where i'm
getting both the value
and um
uh
you know people are asking here that
would be an amusing thing to put in
i mean uh to put smp
into the into the um into external
evaluate
boy that's a weird idea i had not
thought of that idea thank you guys for
that
idea that is that is a deeply weird idea
i mean we could do it um
you know i think uh i i'm not sure i
would recommend it necessarily i think
i i would like to think that all the
good ideas um
from smp were captured in language um
oh my gosh reboot failed
how could my reboot have failed help
i'm rebooting a virtual machine that
thinks it's 1986 right now
well i don't know whoa
let's try one more time and then i give
up
um
but uh uh that is a very amusing idea to
put the syntax on the value it's a good
good internish project at some point to
try and make that work
um there we go
well i don't recommend i mean i i'm i'm
um
oh dear
okay um
yeah me took an easter egg ethan says
yeah it's a that's a
i agree that's a it's an amusing thing
it's it's um i mean the c
code is is runnable i think i mean it's
obviously running here
although you know what it's running
inside a virtual machine that thinks
it's 1986
which may be necessary to get all the
system calls to work and so on
um anyway okay let's go back to position
um uh okay right
all the time sandra is saying he writes
all the time ordering
hash com minus one ampersand
what does that even do the
i hate to be confused here but um
i think this will be mapping over a list
of lists
so ordering minus one gives you the
largest the sorry the position of the
largest
the position of the largest right right
right right trigger charge okay that's
what i
okay yes
okay so um
i see
[Music]
so that's that's exactly what we're
talking about here
right well there is a problem of what
happens if there are two times
10 in that list so the natural thing to
return is a list
of
well is that what this is doing this is
not what this is doing right because
this
no it's just giving you one but for
example say minus two
ordering minus two yeah then we'll give
two of those
right right
um so we have a few ways of doing this
but it's true that
they are obscure enough that it's not
easy to think of them
right i mean for example i haven't used
this i'm sure i knew it at one time
this ordering minus one thing
um
okay and what is the other way of doing
it
so so the so the preferred way or the
way i use right now is technologist
because usually i want both the element
and the index at the same time
that's very useful
okay i should be using that i haven't
been using that
right so you're saying that if i say
position the maximum i can get
by saying let's say i i say um
and then i say take largest
that arrow index
comma one right oh can i just do that
no you have to specify a number
okay but they're in fact two of them
right so this function doesn't know that
you have to specify
the name there right
right but then if i say here
yes and you can also say all arrow all
will give you associations with all the
information it has
that's nice i mean i'm not using this
but it's nice
and with with the buy function it also
it's
now also able to to give you both the
value
before and after the application of the
function
that was a suggestion
external suggestion by sander
i should mention
why didn't that work you're in 12 too
yeah did i did i get this the wrong way
around yes i did
so value is the value of the bide thing
right yes
that's nice
you know i have to say that something
like position max is kind of one of
these functions that one just imagines
should exist
and it would help if the documentation
search
would take one immediately to something
like this um
well i mean you're making a reasonable
case that we have a way to do this that
isn't that bad
uh and also that has flexibility
for all these different cases like what
happens if there is a
i mean there's always going to be at
least one largest but there might be a
tie
well that's why i brought up the issue
of you know using ordering versus
take largest because they behave
differently in that
setting right well ordering has a
secondary ordering i don't know what
tech largest
what is take largest secondary sort
oh it's not the the sorting
i mean there is such a sort and i don't
remember um
if it's first come you know first seen
or what but um
or or just the the you know default sort
but
uh ordering whatever negative one will
just give you
one position whereas take largest
with you know goes to index will give
you all positions
of the largest element if there's more
than one
no but i i think in that sense they
behave
similarly because you have to specify
the number of elements you want
these functions to take largest sorry
well if you say take largest give me the
largest
element it's going to give you all of
them
no take largest you have to say give me
the three largest
and then if if two happen to be equal
that's fine but i think that's
all there is yeah you always have to
give it the number of elements you want
okay i was misremembering like which
means you don't preemptively just get to
say a tie however big the tie is
right yeah so the the ball from function
repo function
does that position largest
yes
no sorry try with only
one argument
and if it's if it is repeated oh it will
give you only one yeah so it doesn't do
it either
so yeah so that's
perhaps the missing piece here being
able to find how many times the largest
cup years
ethan is saying
not just maximum needs selection and
pattern
lots of times you want the position and
value of the top n
based on some criterion sorted in some
way
i think that's position largest buy you
specify the criterion
with the buy function
yes but opposition
by i don't think it has to be largest by
positioned by
well we take largest by with the
extension of the rule
you can get the index
also what are you suggesting here
i'm saying that we take largest by list
rule index
we can also generalize this to a
criterion
oh it take largest buy exactly take it
largest pie
with the arrow notation
and then the buy function and the number
yeah i mean i understand that this will
work right
this is the position max thing
but max is no max is the default
uh what's how should i say so the
function there
is the thing to be applied for example
imagine you say abs
take largest by abs and then you have a
list of
with positives and negative numbers yep
right yes max is the right you're
sorting numerically
eventually exactly
well so what's your point and your point
is that
take the largest with just
list arrow index will give you the
n largest things we'll give you the
positions of the end largest things
so i i think this list goes to index
is effectively positioned by yeah i know
i'm just not that keen on on having
yes i agree with you it's just difficult
to think of this
name when you're thinking of position by
right
this needs more thought
all right i think we should wrap up with
out of time here
we're going to get to these so in a
previous meeting we looked at this first
group
and we talked about some of these
functions to developers etc so
so now there is a second group of
functions we could look at and i
separate them in subgroups
okay all right well that would be a good
thing to do i mean we've got some
by the way i don't know which group we
should be dealing with this in but
we have got to generalize map and
particularly parallel map
to show progress it's driving me crazy
every time i use parallel map i end up
using parallel map monitored
function repository entry because by the
time i'm using parallel map
i know it's a big crunchy computation
there's no reason i'd be using parallel
map
except for a big country computation and
parallel map monitor does an
excellent job of you know telling me how
fast things are going and so on now it's
not perfect
but it's still i can tell you having
used it thousands of times now
that it does well enough to be extremely
useful
so i i want to make sure and i don't
know which group that is i guess it's
roman who's dealing with the parallel
functionality
i think at least for the parallel
functions let's just put in
preemptive monitoring that sounds like a
primetime
lcc topic
i guess or or maybe it's a ece
um
thing i mean basically roman look
now that we have the progress framework
it should be pretty easy for roman to
hook this up
could you at least ask him that and ask
him to look at parallel map monitored
and see whether he can see how to make
that a system level thing
yeah yeah sure um
all right uh
okay well we should wrap up here's a
little little i mean we we've we've
kicked the tires on some things but we
haven't come to
big conclusions um i i do think there's
a lot more to be said about the whole
debugging issue
um and there's uh yeah there's
lots lots more issues here um but we're
making progress
so thanks everybody thanks to folks on
the live stream for your
input and participation and um
see you again soon